[Music]
straight ahead on law on crime daily
piecing together clues in the
disappearance of gabby potito i ran to
the computer looked through the footage
and lo and behold gabby's van was right
there hear from the youtubers who helped
find potido's missing van as a search
for missing fiance brian laundry
continues plus the defense calls its
first witness in the federal trial of r
kelly but is a former police officer
giving shaky testimony with inconsistent
answers then the murder of suzanne
morphy we scour hundreds of pages of
court documents with explosive details
while the investigators are pointing the
finger at her husband for her
disappearance and later scott peterson
did not get a fair trial nearly 20 years
after his wife's murder convicted killer
scott peterson may soon see a new trial
why a juror may plead the fifth
regarding her alleged misconduct in the
case law on crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with a story captivating
the nation the fbi now confirms remains
found in wyoming are those of gabby
potito meanwhile fiance brian laundry
remains missing
on tuesday the search for laundry picked
back up with the governor of florida
ordering all state agencies to assist in
the search
laundry was last seen last tuesday when
he told family he was backpacking in a
florida reserve on friday laundry's
parents told police they hadn't seen him
in days
florida officials then spent the weekend
searching for him the search was called
off but began again on tuesday on
september 1st laundry returned to his
florida home driving potito's van
without her she was reported missing on
september 11th patina was last seen in
late august near grand teton national
park in wyoming the teton county coroner
now confirms that remains found over the
weekend are gabby petito her death has
ruled a homicide but a cause of death
has not yet been released
ahead of an autopsy law on crime daily
sat down with joseph scott morgan a
forensic death investigator he says
decomposition process already began by
the time patil's body was found
it will be
what we would classify as moderate
to significant at this point
i can give you an idea that her body
unprotected even if she had clothing on
her you would begin to see some signs
some signs of skeletonization
that had begun to take place the body
would not be totally skeletonized she'd
still have some soft tissue they're
going to be looking at her head
significantly to see if there's any kind
of fracturing along skull that's
something that decomposition is not
going to compromise
we're also hearing new audio from a
9-1-1 call made by someone nearby in
arches national park fellow guests of
the park reported a domestic incident
between potito and laundry weeks before
she went missing police responded to the
incident involving the pair body camera
video was later released law and crime
obtained the audio from that emergency
call
what were they doing
uh we drove by and the gentleman was
slapping the girl who's slapping her
yes and then we stopped they ran up and
down the sidewalk he proceeded to hit
her hopped in the car and they drove off
we're also hearing directly from the
youtubers who camera recorded what was
likely gabby patil's van in wyoming late
last month
that led to the discovery of the body
that matched potato's description law on
crime's angel levy has more
jen and kyle bethune travel the country
and document all of it on their red
white and bethune youtube channel little
did they know they would record a piece
of video that changed the search for
gabby petito
the video of the white van pulled off of
the side of the road at the spread creek
campsite in wyoming has gone viral jen
bethune said she discovered the van
after receiving an instagram
notification from someone asking that
she check her footage she immediately
called the fbi so we found it about 1205
am sunday morning and we called the
authorities at 1208 once i located their
um information
when i called them i had goosebumps like
i had chills and i was just like i found
her van like patched me through to
somebody hours later authorities
searched the area and later announced
they'd made a grim discovery a body
matching gabby potito's description had
been found
you know we don't want to take any
credit for anything you know we just did
what anybody would do if we thought it
was the right thing it's the pivot point
in this case forensic death investigator
joseph scott morgan discusses the
significance of the bethune's video
this area is so
vast what are the odds
that the police and anybody else that
was involved in the search were actually
going to find a body
this actually turned the entire case
around if you look at the bethune's
video you can see a hat on the dash you
see the same hat in the body camera
video from the traffic stop in moab utah
on august 12th where police separated
brian laundry and gabby potito the
bethunes say petito's mother thanked
them for handing over the video
we just really feel for the family and
at this point we're just trying to
support the family as much as we
possibly can
jen bethune actually calls this all an
amazing mistake because kyle had
accidentally left the gopro on when it
recorded those images of the white van
for law and crime daily i'm angenette
levy
thanks angeannette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney bernardo
violona and terry austin bernardo as a
former homicide prosecutor what are you
looking for in this upcoming autopsy to
give some insight as to what happened to
potito
so the most important elements that
we're looking for in an autopsy is
absolutely what is the cause of death
and what is the manner of death because
if the manner of death is not determined
to be a homicide then there is no
criminal case having to deal with a
murder or any homicide charges in terms
of what caused the death are there any
puncture wounds are there any bullet
holes are there any skull fractures or
bone fractures we're looking at all of
this because an autopsy is an internal
as well as an external examination as
well as a toxicology is also done to see
if there's any kind of narcotics or foul
play within her system absolutely terry
the search is on for laundry but the
longer it takes for him to be caught or
turn himself in doesn't that kind of
hurt him at this point
absolutely brian taking the fifth is one
thing but when you flee the scene it
means that there is some consciousness
of guilt and what makes this even worse
is the fact that the laundry family is
saying they have no idea where he is and
now according to their attorneys they
are not having any further comments so
this is going to just make it far more
complicated for the authorities to find
him he's been missing since 9 14 meaning
you know a few days now almost a week
and the longer it takes to find him the
more difficult the more expense it is
it's going to be harder for him when
they finally do capture him yeah of
course when they find him there's going
to be the argument as to whether or not
he's a flight risk and at this point the
judge may remand him or even set
extremely high bail so we'll see how
that plays out if and when they do find
him thank you both still ahead on law
and crime daily more on the murdoch
family murder mystery a detailed look of
all the twists and turns but first the
prosecution has officially arrested an r
kelly sex crimes trial how the defense
begins its case in the trial against the
r b singer
[Music]
welcome back the federal case of r kelly
heats up as the defense takes center
stage on monday kelly's team called its
first witness who testified with some
mixed
messages
defense lawyers called former chicago
police officer larry hood to the stand
kelly's longtime friend and former
security guard to start hood said he
never saw kelly commit any abuse or
interact with underage girls later
testimony contradicted this though when
hood confirmed kelly was with aliyah
when she was 12 or 13. earlier in the
trial prosecutors called upon an r kelly
accuser who stated hood was present at r
kelly's chicago apartment when he had
sexual relations with underage girls on
monday hood denied ever seeing anyone in
kelly's chicago apartment besides the
singer himself kelly faces multiple
charges at the federal level including
sex trafficking and racketeering he pled
not guilty to all
defense charges bernardo villalona and
terry austin to break down our kelly's
defense terry is this a logical or even
persuasive defense putting on people who
didn't see abuse but so many have
already said it's happened to them
couldn't hood have just not been there
for the abuse
listen hood probably was there for the
abuse this is really going to come down
to a question of credibility first he
said he never saw any young girls at the
apartment then of course he changed that
very quickly when they talked about
aaliyah being there and we know that
angela was also previously on the stand
one of his other victims and she said
that he was there so the question of
credibility comes to the fact that he's
a close friend of r kelly he's a former
police officer and he left under
disgraced circumstances for forgery so i
think the jury is going to not believe
him and believe what the accusers have
been saying i would agree with you there
bernardo day two of the defense's case
saw an assistant studio engineer an
accountant testify what are we getting
from these witnesses and did the judge
say when the jury may get the case
so brian with day two of testimony we're
seeing that common pattern and that
common pattern amongst the defense
witnesses is that look i didn't see
anything i didn't hear anything r kelly
did nothing wrong here today we had mr
meeks who came in and testified that he
had known r kelly for 13 years he
started out as an intern and then worked
in other of his business and in that he
never saw r kelly mistreat any type of
woman and there were no locks on the
door in addition he also called his
accountant who said that he had worked
with him for a couple of years took him
out of 12 million dollars in debt to
three million dollars in debt and that
he also saw no wrongdoing on r kelly's
part this is all a fabrication
right we'll see how the jury interprets
it i know the locked door aspect was a
big thing for the defense i'm not sure
if that's going to carry the day but of
course when the jury gets the case and
we hear closing arguments that will
paint a better picture as to where the
defense is going with their case thank
you both switching gears now a double
murder botched assistant suicide plan
insurance fraud and theft the murder
murder mystery continues to send
shockwaves across the country our chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
breaks down the tangle web of alec
murdoch's past few months and brings us
the latest developments in the story
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates we'll get the
latest from south carolina in that
twisted tragic sega of the bernal family
an insider's look on what to expect next
in the investigation alec murdoch last
week was charged with basically trying
to orchestrate his own murder to cash in
on a 10 million dollar life insurance
policy purportedly to help his son his
remaining son uh things didn't go well
he ended up admitting to investigators
we were told that this was the case uh
the man they arrested along with him was
a 61 year old guy
who was a former logger who um
murdoch's attorneys have said it was his
primary drug dealer
that's coming up this week on brian ross
investigates on the long crime trial
network brian
thanks brian ross coming up on law on
crime daily can a convicted killer scott
peterson get a new trial how alleged
jeremy's conor can possibly free this
charged murderer plus new court
documents released for another man
accused of killing his wife what this
lengthy affidavit reveals about barry
murphy's marriage
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
newly released court documents bring
shocking new details to light against
accused wife killer barry morphew
a 131-page affidavit paints a colorful
picture of the life barry and suzanne
morphy shared more than a dozen times
morphew denied knowledge of his wife's
affair even calling his marriage quote
perfect but text message between the
couple shows a different story as
suzanne tech said quote i'm done and
let's handle this civilly the affidavit
also points to the recording of a march
2020 fight between the pair after
suzanne confided in her friend that
barry quote won't speak a divorce the
friend bought suzanne a spy pen to
record their conversations suzanne moore
if you went missing on mother's day 2020
in a video barry morview claimed she was
kidnapped and begged for her return
authorities say it was an act and that
he actually killed her last week a judge
ruled that murphy's trial will begin on
may 3rd of next year he faces several
charges including first degree murder
and tampering with a deceased human body
back for their take on morpheus
affidavit is criminal defense attorney
bernardo violone and co-host terry
austin terry lawn crimes adams class
fell wrote an article on the website
that i recommend to everyone actually
check out listing five of the most
eye-popping facts in this 131 page
affidavit which one shocked you the most
well they all shocked me brian actually
but the internet searches i think were
the ones that were a bit disturbing he
does admit that he looked at porn but
he's saying he never went on any dating
sites and some of the sites they found
were about younger girls finding a cute
girl near selita and he said that he
never did that and he denied that he
ever had any problems with his marriage
and frankly it would have been better
for him i think to admit to some of the
problems particularly since they've come
up on his phone and to just say he yes
looked at some porn and maybe they were
pop-ups and he did mention that but i
think he should have just
confronted them and told him the truth
about everything on his phone yeah
that's not too incriminating in terms of
what he's being charged with considering
all the other facts bernardo what do
these text messages give the prosecution
if his case goes to trial
well what the text messages gives the
prosecution is motive motive motive
motive pure motive prosecutor doesn't
have to prove motive however motive does
help a jury try to decide why is it that
this person killed this other person and
here you have motive
as well as you're discrediting him with
him saying that he did not know that she
was cheating on him
absolutely it makes sense and they'll
definitely intertwine that in terms of
the story telling if this case does go
to trial that along with some of the
little lies that he's making i think
will make for a strong prosecution case
thank you both and in florida a murder
suspect has officially pled not guilty
to all charges
brian potter was found murdered outside
of his apartment in kendall florida back
in november 2006. former teammate
rashawn jones has long been suspected
but was never arrested due to a lack of
evidence fifteen years later cell phone
data placed jones in the area the day
and time of the murder patta and jones
were involved in confrontations before
the shot was fired on friday prosecutors
formally filed second-degree murder
charges against jones with the
possibility of upgrading to first degree
once the prosecutors present the case to
a grand jury
when we come back the next steps for
scott peterson the shocking new filings
by his defense why the convicted wife
killer's attorneys are asking for
immunity for the one of the jurors who
decided his fate next
[Music]
welcome back an update now on the story
law and crime daily has been following
for months the trial before the man
accused of killing his wife children and
dog has been pushed back
the trial of anthony dot was originally
set to begin on monday but prosecutors
requested more time to sift through
large amounts of evidence prosecutors
say todd murdered his wife three kids
and the family dog in january 2020. the
family was renting a home in celebration
florida originally developed by the walt
disney company and nearby the orlando
theme parks in december 2019 the rental
homes landlord attempted to evict the
family after nearly five thousand
dollars in rent money went unpaid while
todd originally confessed to the murders
he later suggested his wife was
responsible todd has entered a plea of
not guilty he is due back in court on
october 18th
and jury selection is underway in
arizona for mark gooch a u.s airman who
is accused of murdering sasha krauss a
mennonite schoolteacher krauss
disappeared from her community in
january 2020 her remains were found over
a month later an autopsy revealed she
died of blunt force trauma and a gunshot
wound to the head cell phone records and
surveillance video put gooch at the
scene of the crime previous cell phone
records obtained show that gooch and his
brothers show contempt towards those in
the mennonite faith mark gooch is
charged with first-degree murder and
faces life in prison if found guilty
turning now to the west coast where
scott peterson is set to appear in court
on wednesday as his defense team inches
closer to the promise of a new trial
peterson was convicted of the 2002 death
of his wife lacey and their unborn son
connor in 2005 he was given the death
penalty but the sentence was later
reduced to life without parole after the
california supreme court cited
significant errors in the jury selection
it's on those grounds of germ misconduct
that peterson's defense teams say the
court owes him a new trial juror number
seven later revealed to be richelle
niece failed to disclose domestic abuse
in her past peterson's defense argued
nice purposely tried to convict him
because of her past issues court
documents show peterson's defense saying
nice will plead the fifth amendment at
wednesday's evidentiary hearing unless
granted immunity from the prosecution
after an appearance last month one of
peterson's defense attorneys addressed
the dispute with juror 7.
i think it is somewhat
difficult
for us to understand why they don't want
the truth to come out
we find it very difficult to understand
why they wouldn't as
prosecutors and as
their role to do justice why they
wouldn't want the information about
rochelle nice to come out
we are perplexed by that and don't
understand why it is that they continue
to fight this when all we are trying to
do is get it the truth
now bernardo it's absolutely the
prosecution decision to give or not give
nice immunity but why wouldn't they in a
case this serious for several reasons
one you do not want to reward bad
behavior you don't want a reward of
giving immunity to a potential juror
that lied under oath because that's
technically what you're doing when
you're giving her immunity but two is
like what can she reveal she can reveal
some information that can cause for a
new trial to be ordered in this case and
the prosecution probably doesn't want to
go through a trial all over again which
is sad because in the end it's like
because you were a victim
does not mean that you're not qualified
to be a juror what would have happened
is that there would have been further
inquiry to see whether you can still
remain fair and impartial absolutely now
terry with nina saying she plead the
fifth where do you think that would
leave peterson in terms of getting a new
trial
well it all depends on how the judge
looks at that information frankly the
fact that she's pleading the fifth means
that she's hiding something and what is
she hiding the fact that she may have
understood the questions that were being
asked during voir dire and that she
intentionally kept that information from
the attorneys and from the court so i
think that the judge when this hearing
this evidentiary hearing does occur is
going to have to figure out what else we
need in terms of information do we talk
to other jurors how are we going to find
out what in fact this juror knew or the
judge could very well hold it against
her and come to the conclusion that she
in fact was withholding information and
in fact peterson is deserving of a new
trial so much depends on what happens at
that hearing yeah it's all about
interpretation at that point we'll see
how that plays out as we continue to
follow this case thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you